GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
A BIG MOVE BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, ITS STRONGEST
METHOD YET FOR JURISDICTION THAT
PROVIDE SAFE HAVENS TO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
JEFF SESSIONS ANNOUNCING A
LAWSUIT AGAINST CALIFORNIA.
>> CALIFORNIA, WE HAVE A PROBLEM
>> CALIFORNIA, WE HAVE A PROBLE
PROBLEM.
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATOR
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATOR          L
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATOR          G
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATOR          S
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATOR          A
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATOR          O
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATOR          R
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATOR          A
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATOR          D
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATOR          T
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATOR          R
TO INTENTIONALLY OBSTRUCT THE
WORK OF OUR SWORN IMMIGRATION
OFFICERS.
THE DEPARTMENT FILED A SUIT
AGAINST THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
TO INVALIDATE THESE UNJUST LAWS
AND IMMEDIATELY FREEZE THEIR
AFFECT.
I FUNDAMENTALLY BELIEVE THAT MY
CORE THAT WE SHOULD NOT FURTHER
ENDANGER THE LIVES OF THOSE WHO
RISK EVERYTHING FOR US BECAUSE
SOME OFFICIALS WANT TO VIOLATE
THE LAW IN PROMOTING AN AGENDA
THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE REJECT.
>> Kimberly: SESSIONS CALLED
OUT THE MAYOR WHO WARNED
ILLEGALS LAST MONTH THAT THE
FEDS WERE COMING.
>> THE MAYOR OF OAKLAND HAS
ACTIVELY, HAS BEEN ACTIVELY
SEEKING TO HELP ILLEGAL ALIENS
AVOID APPREHENSION BY I.C.E.
HERE IS MY MESSAGE TO
MAYOR SCHAAF.
HOW DARE YOU NEEDLESSLY ENDANGER
THE LIVES OF OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS TO PROMOTE A RADICAL
OPEN BORDERS AGENDA.
>> Kimberly: CALIFORNIA'S
GOVERNOR RESPONDED WITH SOME
FIRE OF HIS OWN.
>> THIS IS REALLY UNPRECEDENTED.
TURN FOR THE CHIEF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OF THE UNITED STATES
TO COME OUT TO CALIFORNIA AND
ACT MORE LIKE FOX NEWS THEN A
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
THIS IS A POLITICAL STUNT, AND
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE TRUTH.
IT'S NOT ABOUT PROTECTING OUR
STATE.
IT IS ABOUT DIVIDING AMERICA.
>> Kimberly: OH, NO, YOU
DIDN'T.
THE STATE GETTING A VISIT FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP NEXT WEEK.
LET'S GO, CALIFORNIA, SHALL WE,
GREG?
>> Greg: I WAS TRIGGERED BY
HIM.
I THINK THERE SHOULD BE A
SANCTUARY CITY FOR FOX NEWS.
AN ENTIRE CITY, JUST LIKE
AIRPORTS FOR CNN.
ENTIRE CITIES WERE ALL YOU CAN
LISTEN TO HIS FOX NEWS.
IN CALIFORNIA, THAT'S A TRUE
SANCTUARY CITY.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM WITH THIS
WHOLE STORY WITH THE MAYOR OF
OAKLAND.
THREE WORDS THAT MAKE ME GIGGLE.
IF YOU FOLLOW THE LAW, AND
YOU'RE BREAKING THE LAW, YOU
REALIZE THIS COULD BE REVERSED.
PEOPLE CAN DO THIS TO YOU TOO.
IF YOU BELIEVE THIS LAW ISN'T
WORTH FOLLOWING, SOMEONE ELSE
CAN DO THAT.
A SANCTUARY CITY FOR THE UNBORN.
I MEAN, THE MEDIA WOULD GO
APOPLECTIC IF YOU SAID HERE'S A
CITY WHERE WE WILL NOT PERFORM
ANY ABORTIONS AT ALL.
THAT WOULD NOT HAPPEN.
HERE YOU CAN DO THAT BECAUSE YOU
AGREE WITH THE LAW.
I THINK WHAT THESE BATTLES ARE
DESIGNED FOR IS TO CREATE
CELEBRITIES.
IF YOU STAND UP AGAINST EVIL
TRUMP, YOU'RE GOING TO BECOME
FAMOUS.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU ARE THE
MAYOR OF OAKLAND WHICH IS LIKE
YOU DON'T HAVE ANY ACHIEVEMENTS.
WHEN YOU ARE THE MAYOR OF
OAKLAND.
BECOME FAMOUS BY STANDING UP TO
EVIL TRUMP.
THAT'S HER ACHIEVEMENT.
>> Kimberly: DANA, WHAT DO YOU
MAKE OF THIS?
IT IS SYMBOLIC.
GOING STRAIGHT TO THE ROOT OF
THE PROBLEM, MAKING AN
APPEARANCE IN TALKING ABOUT THIS
AND IT'S BEEN WIDESPREAD IN
TERMS OF CRITICISM OF
CALIFORNIA, SAN FRANCISCO IN
PARTICULAR IS A SAFE HAVEN FOR
ILLEGALS.
>> Dana: IT'S AN INTERESTING
AND POSSIBLY A GOOD STRATEGY.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS ON
OFFENSE AND THE STATUS ON
DEFENSE.
PREVIOUSLY IT'S BEEN THE FEDS
WERE ON THEIR HEELS.
BY FILING THIS LAWSUIT, THE
STATE IS GOING TO HAVE TO SHOW
UP AND TRY TO DEFEND THEMSELVES
ON THESE CASES.
I AM NOT A LAWYER BUT I THINK
THE SUPREMACY CLAUSE OF THE
CONSTITUTION IS GOING TO BEAR
OUT.
WE KNOW THE COURTS HAVE BEEN ALL
OVER THE PLACE ON THIS.
THIS IS PROBABLY A USEFUL
EXERCISE FOR US TO FIND OUT
WHERE IS THE LAW ON IT?
ON THE POLITICAL SIDE, EVERYONE
GETS TO RALLY.
JERRY BROWN LOVED IT TODAY.
EVERYONE, THE DEMOCRATS WILL
LOVE IT TODAY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PEOPLE WILL
HAVE LOVED WHAT JEFF SESSIONS
DID AND THEY ARE GOING TO GET
EXCITED BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT WILL BE THERE NEXT
WEEK.
SETTING UP FOR HIGH NOON.
AT THE BORDER.
I AM CURIOUS ABOUT THE POINT OF
THE MAYOR, THE LEGAL POINT ABOUT
HER TIPPING OFF HER CITIZENS
THAT THE I.C.E. RATE IS COMING.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S ILLEGAL.
BUT IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
ILLEGAL FOR HER TO BE SOUND
WRONG -- FOR IT TO SOUND WRONG.
SOUNDS LIKE THE WRONG THING TO
DO.
IF SHE WAS GIVING A HEADS UP TO
A DRUG LORD THAT THE COPS WERE
COMING AND THERE'S GOING TO BE A
BUST, THAT WOULD BE OBSTRUCTION.
SHE IS TRYING TO HELP THE DRUG
LORDS.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE THIS WOULD
END UP BUT IT DOES FEEL LIKE
IT'S THE WRONG THING TO DO.
>> Jesse: SESSIONS SHOULD
THROW THE BOOK AT THIS MAYOR.
IF IT HAPPENS ONCE AND IT'S
ALLOWED EVERYONE'S GOING TO DO
IT.
I'M GLAD SESSIONS WOKE UP.
I HAVEN'T HEARD FROM HIM IN A
WHILE.
THAT'S GOOD.
I THINK GOVERNOR MOONBEAM IS
GOING TO GO DOWN.
THE LAW IS NOT ON THE SIDE.
HIS STATE IS PREVENTING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FROM
CONDUCTING RAIDS AND DOING THEIR
JOBS.
THEY DID A RAID THE OTHER DAY.
LOOK AT THESE NASTY PEOPLE.
232 ILLEGALS ARRESTED.
180 OF THEM CONVICTED CRIMINALS.
LOOK AT SOME OF THE CRIMES VERY
SERIOUS OFFENSES.
CHILD SEX CRIMES, WEAPONS
CHARGES, ASSAULT.
SOME HAD BEEN BACK AND FORTH
ACROSS THE BORDER NUMEROUS TIMES
ACROSS THE BORDER NUMEROUS TIME
TIMES.
THESE ARE BAD HOMBRES.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THE
DEMOCRATS DON'T GET THAT.
STATES HAVE CLASHED OVER ISSUES
FOR YEARS.
OVER POT, MARRIAGE, VOTER I.D.
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
NOW IT'S OVER IMMIGRATION.
THE DIFFERENCE HERE, IT'S ABOUT
PUBLIC SAFETY.
LET'S PRETEND SOMETHING.
JUAN, IF SOME LOCAL GUN DEALER
WASN'T COMPLYING WITH THE
FEDERAL BACKGROUND CHECKS WHEN
THEY SOLD WEAPONS, SAY I DON'T
AGREE WITH IT.
I DON'T LIKE THE DATABASE WITH
THE FBI.
I'M NOT GOING TO COOPERATE, IT'S
THE SAME KIND OF THING.
IT'S DANGEROUS.
THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD AT LEAST
ADMIT THEY ARE PRO-OPEN BORDERS
AND PRO-IMMIGRATION BECAUSE
EVERYONE WOULD EVENTUALLY KNOW.
>> Juan: THAT'S VERY
INTERESTING.
>> Kimberly: TWO DIFFERENT
VIEWPOINTS FROM MEN IN PURPLE
TIES.
>> Juan: THIS IS SO ABSURD.
THE MAYOR OF OAKLAND IS NOT
GETTING IN THE WAY OF THE LAW.
SHE IS NOT STOPPING THEM FROM
CONDUCTING THEIR RATES, NOT AT
ALL.
>> Jesse: SHE TIPPED THEM OFF.
>> Juan: SHE INFORMALLY
LEARNED THESE RATES WERE COMING.
TO DEAL WITH A HIGH LEVEL OF
ANXIETY AND THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY SPECIFICALLY.
>> Jesse: OH, THESE POOR
ILLEGAL ALIEN RAPISTS ARE
GETTING ANXIOUS.
THE PEOPLE YOU ARE STICKING UP
FOR.
>> Juan: LET'S GET AMERICAN
RAPISTS OFF THE STREETS.
THERE ARE THREE THINGS AT STAKE
ACCORDING TO XAVIER BECERRA.
HE SAYS HE'S NOT GOING TO ALLOW
COPS TO ASK PEOPLE ABOUT
CITIZENSHIP.
IT IS NOT LIKE PAPERS, PLEASE.
IF YOU STOP SOMEBODY AT A
STOPLIGHT, YOU CAN'T JUST START
ASKING PEOPLE BACK.
NO WORKPLACE RAIDS WITHOUT A
SUBPOENA OR WARRANT.
FINALLY, NO CONTRACT WITH
FOR-PROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
COME IN AND GRAB PEOPLE AND HOLD
THEM FOR THE FEDS.
THIS IS NOT INTERFERING WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR RIC.
THIS IS SAYING LOCAL MONEY AND
LOCAL AUTHORITY UNDERSTANDS
THAT, AS JESSE SAID, THIS IS A
PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE.
YOU WANT THE IMMIGRANTS IN YOUR
STATE, IN YOUR CITY TO COOPERATE
WITH POLICE AND NOT BE AFRAID.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE NOT GOING TO
GET DEPORTED FOR DROPPING A
DIME.
THAT NEVER HAPPENS.
IF YOU SNITCH, THAT'S A GOOD
THING AND HE AGREED TO KEEP YOU
HERE.
>> Juan: ALLOW ME TO MAKE MY
LARGER POINT.
I THINK THIS IS A DISTRACTION.
I'M SURPRISED YOU'RE PUTTING
DOWN TRUMP'S ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> Jesse: HAVEN'T HEARD A LOT
FROM HIM.
>> Juan: MAYBE HE IS APPEASING
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND SETTING UP
FOR HIS VISIT NEXT WEEK BECAUSE
HE FEELS LIKE MAYBE A --
>> Dana: YOU DON'T THINK JEFF
SESSIONS BELIEVES THAT?
>> Juan: I THINK HE IS PUSHING
THE SUIT BECAUSE IT'S THE NEWS
OF THE DAY.
THE SECOND THING IF MAYBE HE
DOESN'T WANT PEOPLE TO FOCUS ON
WHY HIS WIFE GOT INTO THE
COUNTRY ON A SO-CALLED EINSTEIN
EXCEPTION.
EINSTEIN, REALLY?
SHE IS IN EINSTEIN?
>> Greg: YOU DON'T THINK SHE
IS SMART?
>> Juan: HOW DID HER PARENTS
GET IN?
CHAIN MIGRATION.
I THOUGHT HE HATED CHAIN
MIGRATION BUT NOT WHEN IT'S HIM.
>> Jesse: I THINK MELANIA
QUALIFIES FOR MERIT-BASED.
>> Juan: I SAY YOU SHOULD --
[ALL SPEAKING]
>> Greg: THERE AREN'T ANY
CREDIBLE STATISTICS THAT TALK
ABOUT HOW THIS ISSUE AFFECTS
COOPERATION WITH POLICE.
I HAVEN'T SEEN IT AND I'VE BEEN
LOOKING FOR IT.
YOU SAID I'M NOT A LAWYER AND
WHERE IS THE LAW?
NO REAL WINNER -- THE REAL
WINNERS ARE LAWYERS.
EVERY ISSUE, IT ALWAYS GOES BACK
TO LAWYERS AND CASES AND GOING
TO COURT.
IT REALLY IS GETTING BORING FOR
ME.
BRINGS ME TO MY NEXT POINT,
WHERE IS THIS GOING?
IS THIS WORTH FIGHTING OR DYING
FOR?
VIOLATE THE LAW TO ALLOW
SYMBOLIC OR REAL SANCTUARY FOR
ILLEGAL ALIENS, WHICH JESSE
POINTS OUT THE ONES BEING
ARRESTED ARE CRIMINALS.
IS THIS SOMETHING YOU ARE
WILLING TO FIGHT AND DIE FOR?
DO YOU THINK THIS IS AS BIG AS A
FIGHT AGAINST SLAVERY OR CIVIL
RIGHTS OR THE WOMEN'S RIGHT TO
VOTE.
DO YOU ACTUALLY BELIEVE THAT.
YOU AND RATHER PUT OUR COUNTRIES
LAWS FOR THE SAKE OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, SOME ARE ACTUALLY
CRIMINAL.
>> Juan: YOU SHOULD CHECK THE
NUMBERS.
MOST AMERICANS NOT ONLY SUPPORT
THE DREAMERS, THEY SUPPORT THE
IDEA THAT THE PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN
HERE, 11 MILLION SHOULD BE
ALLOWED --
>> Greg: I SUPPORT THE
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT THAT.
>> Kimberly: TALKING ABOUT A
VERY DIFFERENT GROUP.
LET'S DISTINGUISH BETWEEN THE
DREAMERS AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
CRIMINAL PREDATORS, CRIMINAL
RECIDIVISTS.
>> Greg: THE ARGUMENT YOU USE
WHENEVER WE TALK ABOUT RADICAL
ISLAM AND YOU ACCUSES OF
TAINTING ALL OF ISLAM.
YOU ARE DOING THAT.
YES, YOU ARE.
>> Juan: WHAT I WAS SAYING TO
KIMBERLY WAS ALL THE PEOPLE HERE
ILLEGALLY, AND I HOPE YOU HEAR
THIS, JESSE, ARE NOT CRIMINALS.
>> Greg: THE ARGUMENT.
>> Kimberly: GOD-FEARING,
LAW-ABIDING PEOPLE WHO COME INTO
THIS COUNTRY FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES AND THEY GET, OBTAIN
CITIZENSHIP LIKE MY FATHER WHO
CAME FROM IRELAND.
MY MOTHER MOVED FROM PUERTO RICO
TO SAN FRANCISCO.
WORKED HARD, WORKED JOBS IN THE
CITY, WORKED AS A TEACHER, DID
THE WHOLE THING.
THEY WEREN'T TRYING TO VIOLATE
ANY LAWS.
THEY WON'T COMMIT ANY CRIMES.
THERE'S A HEALTHY INTEREST,
BELIEVE ME, I'M PART OF THE
LATINO COMMUNITY OF WHICH I AM
ONE OF THE MEMBERS TO MAKE SURE
THE LAWS ARE UPHELD IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THAT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO TO
BE LAW-ABIDING AND RESPECTFUL OF
THOSE WHO WANT TO COME IN.
YOU CAN STILL HAVE AN OPEN
POLICY WHILE RESPECTING THE
LOSS.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE THE TWO BEST
PARADES.
>> Kimberly: THEY ARE A LITTLE
UNRULY.
WE CAN ALL CONCUR.
>> Juan: YOU HAVE TO WATCH OUT